bonjour tiendrait le berthod brousse et
à merci de répondre à nos questions tout
d'abord où on est votre client
christophe wilson est ce qu'il est
toujours en garde à vue et son cuisinier
est ce qu'il est toujours en rétention
non plus au buisson est sorti hier à 17
heures après 24 heures de garde à vue et
le cuisinier n'est pas un rite à sion
mais là ce qu'on appelle une demande de
bois quitté voilà quitter le territoire
français et monsieur wilson qui s'est
expliqué pendant la garde à vue expliqué
parce que l'on a parlé tout de suite de
que y avait des faits graves
il avait travaillé c'est que plus il est
maître mot des sinon je me dire tout de
suite d'une brillante et claire que au
pot peas
il n'y avait pas de salariés clandestins
il avait un contrat travail et déclaré
la sécurité sociale avec une déclaration
pour la bonne bouche qui a été fait dans
les formes par l'expert comptable des
fiches de paie les mises aux salariés et
que ces personnes qui n'étaient pas dans
l'illégalité c'est ça pardon ça veut
dire qu'il n'était pas dans l'illégalité
alors alors juridiquement parlant alors
vous savez pour que personne ne puisse
être sanctionné il faut que l'acte a été
commis intentionnellement
or si on me prend on m'apporte des
documents on me portent une carte de
sécurité sociale et que je ne suis pas
policier j'ai communique sans mon
expert-comptable et je découvre
seulement le jour du contrôle que cette
personne ait des personnes qui est
illégalement sur le tour de france et je
n'ai pas commis de délit
parce que le délit et lorsque vous avez
connaissance de la situation irrégulière
de vos salariés disent elle expliqué et
d'ailleurs si des choses ont été
effectivement d'une extrême gravité
serait pas sorti à 17h30 on n'avait pas
connaissance de cela non il n'avait pas
connaissance de cela et s'il avait été
le cas je peux vous dire une chose pour
buvette depuis l'ouverture du restaurant
au public les choses se serait pas
arrêté il sera simplement évoqué
aujourd'hui pour rappel à loi en mode
hybride
parmi eux la défense de votre client je
cite je dois payer mes employés faire
vivre ma famille qu'est ce qu'ils
risquent exactement christophe wilson
n'était que de choses
il ya eu d'abord une approche et je dois
le dire rendre hommage aussi aux
policiers lors de la garde à vue deux
interrogatoires qui n'ont pas été de la
maltraitance n'a été un échange
conscient aussi qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas simplement le cas de chris tomlinson
mais c'est le cas de beaucoup de
beaucoup de restaurateurs et de
commerçants en général n'y a pas que le
restaurateur il ya aussi des centres de
le gymnase de les finesses plein de
commerce la culture la situation de
détresse du commerce et les et
l'existant maintenant tout le monde le
sait tout le monde en parle et aprilia
l'expiration à l'exaspération qui peut
vous amener comme pour certains cas au
suicide
l'exaspération que c'est de dire il
court toujours pour donner à manger à ma
famille pour faire travailler à mes
employés parce que mes recettes que vous
deviez si on lit entre les lignes ça
veut dire que votre client est un
précurseur c'est ça écoutez ce n'est pas
le seuil et déjà d'autres ouvertures en
france aujourd'hui et qui sort peu est
une personne qui a pris le taureau par
les cornes et à travers son acte est un
acte qui est aussi politique
même si il a on peut dire il a bien
décrit en rousse mais la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui est ce que ces décrets
qui composent la fermeture absolue de
restaurants ces décisions sont elles
conformes aux principes constitutionnels
sont elles sont ils conformes aux
principes de nos sociétés parce
qu'aujourd'hui en ériger la santé comme
en principe essentiel alors que dans
notre constitution
c'est la liberté qui le principe est
aujourd'hui on est en train d'animer
toute liberté toute liberté liberté
d'aller et venir de travail et la
liberté d'entreprendre la liberté de
manifester tout est sous contrôle
tout est sous contrôle de l'exécutif et
alors que la liberté est d'essence dans
la société et qui est l'essence même de
la dignité de l'individu
parce qu'aujourd'hui de dire ok on m'a
touché de l'argent où tous les invités
est ce que c'est à la dignité de l'homme
est ce que c'est ça votre dignité de
vivre deux sociétés je parle à l'homme
là je parle pas à l'avocat ça veut dire
que vous soutenez
le choix de christophe wilson d'avoir
ouvert son établissement malgré
l'interdiction
aujourd'hui les 119 soutient tous les
actions qui ont pour une seule pénalité
de rappeler à la france de rappeler à
l'exécutif qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
encore utiliser la santé le communiqué
d'hier par le minsanté le critère de la
santé comme un critère essentiel pour
conduire la politique de la nation non
qu'aujourd'hui tous les actes pour moi
ce n'est pas un acte gravissime ouvrir
le restaurant l'autre sens quand la
santé va tout va c'est important quand
même la santé un nom mais je suis
absolument pas d'accord quand
aujourd'hui ce qui redonne ce passé que
nous sommes en train de laisser les
laisser tous les jours départ de
libertés et quand j'ai aujourd'hui les
locaux laissent ils parlent de liberté
pour la sécurité et pour la santé on ne
retournera plus émond a mérité et
aujourd'hui cela fait des mois et des
mois
la france est le pays d'europe qui
connaît la plus longue fermeture des
activités culturelles les activités
gastronomiques en italie vous avez des
zones jaune orange rouge en ce jour
les restaurants sont ouverts et senna
fait sur le papier des mois et des mois
qu'on en france que les restaurants sont
permis un exploit surtout vers vous
interprétez le comment vous interprétez
le soutien à votre client sur les
réseaux sociaux
est ce que ça veut dire que la boîte de
pandore est ouverte c'est ça ça peut
faire jurisprudence et derrière on peut
y avoir
ça peut faire un effet domino
certainement mais pourquoi c'était plus
domino parce que c'est aux folles au le
révélateur de l'état d'esprit des
français
gp odieux ouverte en deux jours une amie
mais pour dire stop au plus bas
l'association a reçu plus de saint-denis
courriel en 48 heures pour dit stop et
aucunement j'ai une association qui
représente aujourd'hui cinq à sept
personnes
nous allons écrire aujourd'hui opposer
la république pour lui dire les forces
et non un peu plus monsieur le président
les français veulent vivre les français
veulent vivre parce que vous parlez de
la commune 19 vous parlez de la vitalité
de la commune 19 pour parler de 70
mouvements de la commune
mais pour quelle raison on parle pas des
mort de placer pourquoi ne parle pas des
sentiments de maladies cardiovasculaires
et qu'aujourd'hui pour la commune
on est en train de détruire ce qui est
la construction d'un pays qui s'est fait
depuis la révolution française et c'est
inadmissible
c'est inadmissible et ce à un moment
donné il faut avoir le courage de le
dire
et aujourd'hui voilà très bien on va
discuter le compliment pour le moment
mais si le parlement plus rude
sourit toujours des solutions en matière
de liberté alors qu'il était possédé
depuis un an de tous les progressistes
parlementaire qui relèvent de l'article
dans le cadre de solutions et
aujourd'hui on va prêter cacher un
compliment qui va être obligé a
recouvert par le parlement du boîtier ce
n'est pas un choix de l'exécutif
mais c'est un choix commentaire donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes en plein de
vivre une situation de la plaine l'état
de droit ça veut dire c'est construction
harmonieuse doigts qui se fait depuis
1789 s'est effritée en quelques mois il
ya plus de justice le poste et l'état ne
fait que rejeter toutes les décisions de
nos côtés le procès correctionnel il
nous renvoie à lorsqu'il des délais
courts
deux possibilités le parlement
intervient sous des lois liberticides et
tous ceux des libertés prises avec
l'équipe et l'exécutif change décret à
sa guise ce que les besoins de la cause
à nous pendant des programmes juridique
qui n'existe pas je peux rappeler
simplement à tout le monde que nous
avons eu nous avons eu des zones rouges
descendent écarlate et c'est maintenant
mettre en place à nos critères au bout
d'eux à moi tout ça a disparu pourrais
je le disais c'est départ du doigt le
droit c'est une règle permanent général
sont les dispositions réglementaires
doivent adapter ce qu'ils sont des
principes fondamentaux de la merci le
message est passé
carlo alberto brusa rappelle que vous
êtes l'avocat du restaurateur
christophe wilson et président également
de l'association réaction 19